cette reprise il connaît tout il va
falloir vous soyez très exigeante avec
monsieur bart ne sont pas du tout
surprise je reçois du courrier de ce
genre fréquemment et donc je n'apprends
a absolument rien si vous montrer mon
courrier il est quelquefois bien que ça
je le sais parce que vous avez mais là
je me lasse si vous voulez ce n'est pas
que je
je des douanes cet électorat pas du tout
c'est pas du tout que je trouve le choix
parce qu'il m'attaque mais c'est
simplement sur leur idée quand il pense
même qu'on a un petit peu trier là c'est
pas vraiment niveau friel
passer de demande en ce sens au micro il
y avait des choses beaucoup plus
saignante
mais l'info et devant la caméra c'est
resté exactement ce que vous non mais
très bien je veux dire c'est que je
crois tout de même qu'à une part dans
les geôles dans son exigence position
après vous vous parlez toujours de
méfier quand les bacs beaucoup mais
écoutez pour l'instant je ne soutiens
aucun candidat parce qu'il n'est pas
candidat
voilà j'ai simplement dit non je n'ai
pas déclaré alors je suis tout à fait
désolé puisque vous revenez là dessus
avec une espèce de certitudes j'ai
simplement dit que je suis ubf
personne n'ignore je ne cache pas et que
je pensais il ya encore des manques à ça
et que je trouvais qu'il fallait que
l'udf est un candidat aux élections
présidentielles parce qu'une grande
formation politique dans notre système
constitutionnel n'existe pas si elle n'a
pas un candidat aux élections
présidentielles c'est vrai que je trouve
qu'il ya trop d'ambiguïté je relisais
les commentaires qui ont été faits par
une grande partie de la classe politique
au lendemain des déclarations que
j'avais fait sur dreux il ya c'était
très populaire mais je crois que
maintenant il est vraiment la base être
validée après quelques kilos et non
seulement la première mais je dois dire
que j'ai été scellée dans la roue de
personnes pratiquement ne m'a ne m'a
souhaité que les propos tenus ont été
même dans la majorité modérée
extrêmement dur à mon endroit et que le
courrier que j'ai reçu je parlais du
courrier le projet toujours très
intéressant le courrier que j'ai reçue
était aussi
étaient aussi imposant alors je me
réjouis de voir que maintenant tout de
même beaucoup ont pris position de façon
beaucoup plus peur mais c'est vrai vous
avez raison c'est vrai qu'il y en a qui
sont gênés par les déclarations quimper
michel moi qu'après fer russes et malgrè
qu'on peut faire d'autre
je crois que on ne peut plus maintenant
c'est ça me plaît et d'ailleurs je crois
que surtout la classe politique devrait
comprendre qu'elle a tout à y gagner